marvel fans agree the best character in
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
isn't the one in the title they also
think you'll like this roller coaster of
a movie just make sure to do your
homework first here's what the fans are
saying about doctor strange too we
should tell him the truth most of the
early fan reactions to doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness are from
people who have had their minds blown
one twitter user hopped online right
after seeing the mcu flick writing in
all caps of course i just saw doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
it was amazing another fan wrote in
their mini review just saw doctor
strange and wow kudos to marvel for this
one totally went outside what i was
expecting and man really close to horror
almost but the cameos and the deaths
make sure you watch one division first
though that last bar was something many
other viewers agreed with as one fan
confirmed just saw the new doctor
strange it was a lot please watch one
division first otherwise you will be
completely lost the storyline was a bit
all over not going to lie but definitely
worth a watch if you're a marvel fan
other posters describe the sequel the
28th entry in the mcu as more of a
rollercoaster ride than a movie and for
some of them at least that was a good
things thing got out of hand
while there was praise for the
performances in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness one name that
seemed to keep popping up in tweets was
director sam raimi known for his
groundbreaking spider-man trilogy the
evil dead series and other frightening
flicks like drag me to hell raymie has
expertise in both a superhero and horror
genres but surprisingly he hasn't
directed a feature film in any genre
since 2013's oscar great and powerful
his fans were certainly happy to see him
back behind the camera and raved over
the work he did on this mcu sequel one
grateful fan wrote thank you sam raimi
the mcu has never been so close to the
horror genre and i love it we need more
sam raimi in the mcu let's make a marvel
universe around sam raimi we'll call it
earth 666 another viewer was even more
enthusiastic writing watched last night
and i applaud sam raimi for giving the
audience a feast for the eyes and
breathing new life and color into the
mcu i don't care if it's too mainstream
or camphor award shows start the
campaign for elizabeth olsen sam has
become known for this terrorizing cinema
experience
there was plenty of applause for
benedict cumberbatch but believe it or
not he's not the star of this movie
based on fan reactions elizabeth olsen
is a clear champion of doctor strange
with hundreds of tweets absolutely
raving about her performance as wonder
maximoff aka the scarlet witch as one
fan posted sam raimi needs to make more
mcu movies and elizabeth olsen had maybe
the best performance of her career
another fan tweeted multiverse of
madness is amazing so many phenomenal
moments but the thing that i want to say
is if this wasn't a marvel movie
elizabeth olsen would be getting the big
nominations absolutely incredible
performance in an incredible film
mirroring that sentiment was another
user who wrote elizabeth olsen owns the
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness give her all the awards already
her name might not be in the title of
the film but doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness really seems to be
wonders moment it's a very powerful
performance with a very powerful
character
we won't give away the big cameos in the
film but there were definitely some
surprises after a year's worth of rumors
that got slightly out of hand some
spoiler-free reactions for these cameos
highlighted just how spectacular they
were one mcu fan drew a line in the sand
writing multiverse of madness is way way
better than no way home don't get me
wrong i love no way home but after
seeing multiverse of madness it's a
better film when it comes to multiverse
and all the bonkers and epic cameos one
twitter user made a great point in
noting how the brain melting cameos
didn't steal the spotlight from the main
stars writing a blast raymie just
willing out and bringing buckets of
style with him appreciated that it
actually remained focused on strange and
wonder and didn't lose sight of them
with cameos actually felt like a sequel
and not an avengers level event another
person had the same sentiments writing
the cameos are fun but the movie has so
much more to offer everything you've
ever known led you to this moment
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness might primarily focus on steven
strange and wonder maximoff but it
introduced a brand new hero to the mcu
america chavez the most powerful
teenager this side of peter parker
america punches her way to the
multiverse to make a big impression in
her first appearance and audiences were
definitely taken with the newcomer and
her journey one user asked everyone is
talking about how it's wonders movie but
can we mention how awesome america
chavez is another simply stated yeah i'm
gonna need more america chavez something
that kept popping up in tweets about
america was a hope for her inclusion in
a potential future mcu project one
person wrote i love america chavez i'm
hoping for a young avengers project
another agreed writing i'm amazed at how
much i like the character america chavez
i know marvel is building that young
avengers roster for a reason sochi gomez
was excellent
finding a negative fan reaction to dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
was no easy feat many who did have
criticisms of the film balance them out
with positive sentiments but they made
it clear this might be a fun ride but
it's not a perfect movie once a movie
starts you'll understand that you're on
a sam raimi crazy ride and there's no
way to stop it it's bonkers the first
act needed a bit more space to breathe
but other than that i loved it a lot of
the issues people seemed to have with
the film was its pacing at just over two
hours it's not the longest mcu film
considering the story's density some
viewers thought it might have benefited
from a longer run time there were also
viewers who all around were not feeling
dr strange in the multiverse of madness
as one thoughtful film fan put it i
think huge sam raimi fans will like this
movie a lot more than i did between the
over the top cheese a rainy movie gives
you and the final act not fulfilling its
destiny i walked away disappointed
another viewer who was let down wrote it
was good but not as great as i hoped
some feel the movie falls in the middle
ground of the mcu with one fan writing
doctor strange is just mid it's not bad
but it isn't good either anything below
5 out of 10 is not enough but anything
above 5 out of 10 is too much the
multiverse is a big place it seems you
can't please everybody
the nightmare begins
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]